in case you hadn't already noticed
everything is getting super duper gay
corporations have gone gay sports teams
have gone gay and now a beloved cartoon
character from the late 1960s has after
53 years in the closet gone gay too
and as promised here are your Scooby
Snacks
[Applause]
thank you
that's Velma there just absolutely
drooling at the Velma dressed up like a
1970s lady drooling at the site of this
kind of 2022 looking lesbian lady little
of Velma is officially a lesbian
before the year is through I have no
doubt that Mickey will go trans and
Popeye will get into s m but for now
Velma is a lesbian because Hollywood has
in its own words a not so secret gay
agenda but why
why
does Velma after all these years need to
be a lesbian
some people are actually arguing that
Velma has always been a lesbian why
because she's frumpy and has short hair
that's not very nice to lesbians
because Velma doesn't have a boyfriend
Shaggy doesn't have a girlfriend does
that mean that Shaggy's gay
the person Shaggy spends the most time
with his Scooby-Doo does that mean that
shaggy is into that weird bestiality
thing that the Biden nuclear energy guy
photographs himself doing I don't think
so I certainly hope not
why does every single thing
have to be gay including half century
old cartoons
because narrative matters of course
narrative matters more than just about
anything else in politics that's why the
left spend so much time and energy
rewriting the past
whoever controls the past whoever
controls the past controls the present
whoever controls the present controls
the future right now you got to go to
established titles.com Knowles because I
tell you there was a period when I felt
like I wasn't getting no respect no
respect I tell you then that all changed
thanks to established titles now I Am
Lord Michael Knowles and you can be a
lord or a lady as well you can get the
respect that you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
Scotland established titles is a Project
based on an historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
Lance
or Lords and Ladies in English in your
title pack you will be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston Scotland
plus an official certificate with a
Crest your certificate features a unique
plot Number with which you can see the
exact location of your land title packs
from established titles are a fun and
unique gift for any occasion there are
even couple packs because you don't want
to be a Lord and then your poor wife
doesn't get to be a lady with your
certificate you could officially add the
prefix Lord or lady to your credit cards
plane tickets even your dating profiles
at plus established titles commits to
preserving The Woodlands not only in
Scotland but around the planet
they've got Partnerships with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future to help with our
afforestation efforts and for every
order they receive a tree is planted
established titles told me get this
the first 200 people purchasing a title
pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine that's right so
depending on how many of you want to
become a lord or a lady we can build our
own kingdom and that will be a wonderful
and it will be run with an iron fist
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now if you use code
Knolls you'll get on top of that an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com get your gifts right
now and help support the channel
Planned Parenthood is peddling puberty
blockers to kids that the kids that they
that slip through the fingers of Planned
Parenthood the kids who are actually uh
able to live and be born Planned
Parenthood says okay we weren't able to
get you in the womb but we are going to
destroy your bodies and your lives once
you're out of the womb here's the
commercial they're running
there's no one-size-fits-all puberty
experience if you're trans intersex or
non-binary know that you're not the only
one feeling confused
for some intersex people puberty may
start later than age 14.
you might experience some of puberty's
changes and not others and your body may
or may not go through puberty on its own
there are medicines you can take to help
your body start the process like hormone
replacement therapy some people decide
on hormones or surgeries to help their
bodies match up to their gender identity
or how they feel inside about themselves
your gender identity is real you should
be the one to decide what changes you
want to make to your body if you're
transgender or non-binary you may find
that your puberty experiences don't line
up with your gender identity or how you
see yourself that feeling can be
uncomfortable scary and stressful if
that sounds like you know that you're
not alone
there are medicines you can take to
delay puberty for a while they're called
puberty blockers and they work like a
stop sign by holding the hormones
testosterone and estrogen that cause
puberty changes like facial hair growth
and periods puberty blockers are safe
and can give you more time to figure out
what feels right for you man that's the
weirdest episode of Scooby-Doo I ever
saw isn't it I know Velma looks a little
bit different not all that much
different I guess
it's hard even to single out Planned
Parenthood here for this perverted evil
attack on children though it is
obviously both of those things because
the whole culture is doing it because
Scooby Dooby Doo is doing it
so of course Planned Parenthood is going
to do it why why are all these people
doing this
there is an ideological incentive
earlier I said whoever controls the past
controls the president whoever controls
the press and controls the future that's
that's true it's missing a little
something though
there's actually even a an earlier part
to that equation which is
whoever controls the imagination
controls the past
the imagination is what comes first we
don't have really direct access to the
past we only have access to things that
are in the present
we only have access to people who are in
the present and those things and those
people can evoke memories but really
they're they're constituting narratives
and those narratives inform our vision
which is just in our imagination of what
the past is so if you if you in your
imagination
uh see America in the 1950s as a nice
place with two cars in every garage and
a chicken in every pot and basically
stable family lives and basically a good
place
that informs one sense of the past and
that's going to inform how you want to
how you view the present and how you
want to live in the future or if in your
imagination you view America in the 50s
as a racist evil bigoted violent
dangerous terrible evil consumerist
trash Place well that's going to give
you a very different view of the past
and the present and it's going to inform
how you want to live into the future why
is Planned Parenthood
so focused on this narrative why is the
whole left so focused on this narrative
well because they have an ideological
agenda absolutely they want the future
to look a certain way because of how
they view human beings in the world
they also have a huge financial interest
in promoting this stuff
do you think it's just a coincidence
that all the biggest most powerful
forces in the country just so happen to
to adopt the ideological View
in this case transgenderism
that just so happens to hook people at
younger and younger ages on extremely
expensive medical subscriptions that
will require a ton of money it'll be a
huge Money Maker as some Public Health
administrators have talked about here in
Tennessee
and we'll keep them on it their whole
lives
and that just so happened to increase
the corporate and State control over
their lives and their Reliance on
corporations and on the state
yeah it's just a coincidence
that that the the ideological narratives
being painted by the establishment
stand to greatly enrich and Empower that
very same establishment that's just a
coincidence wow lucky for them what a
lucky break no of course not
of course not a lot of this is being
driven by money as well
and as
the The Narrative serves the financial
and political interests of the
establishment
you're seeing the cases of
transgenderism Skyrocket in the UK
there's a new a new tranche of data
released by the gender identity
development service at the UK's Infamous
Tavistock Center
found out that Child and Adolescent
referrals have doubled compared to the
previous year
gids as it is called gids or jids it's
sort of like GIF or GIF now estimates
that over 5 000 Children and adolescents
sought gender related services
in 2021 to 2022 that is a 112 increase
over the previous year
how'd that happen
is Alex Jones right is there something
in the water turning the frogs and
turning Velma and turning everybody gay
and trans he actually was right about
the frogs people don't give him credit
for that but he was right there actually
there was a Yale and EPA study
that found that there were chemicals in
the water that were turning the frogs
into hermaphrodites but that's a point
for another time is it that or do you
think there's a social contagion here
that's that's being compounded that's
being promoted by corporate and state
interests
and and who are the who are the victims
here the victims happen to be these kids
who destroy their bodies who destroy
their lives who become extremely
depressed who who despair even though
there is a way out but there is
irreparable damage that that comes along
with that as well that's what happens
the numbers of course are going to keep
going up because even as normal people
the vast majority of Americans vast
majority of Brits I'm sure think that
this is completely insane and public
opinion polls reflect that and elections
reflect that the the youngin election to
governor in Virginia was largely about
this issue of transiting the kids okay
and he won in a blue state so yeah of
course the people are opposed to this
stuff and yet and yet
it continues to be enshrined in law
what's up with that
what's up with that well because our
political establishment does not reflect
the will of the people much as they want
to prattle on about our sacred democracy
they don't give a damn about our
democracy they hate democracy they hate
it when the people vote against their
interests all they care about is their
version of liberalism and they're going
to impose it they're going to impose it
like a like a Jack boot on our necks and
and they're going to have the temerity
to call it democracy and when we fight
back they're going to have the temerity
to call us threats against democracy
speaking of pushing these narratives
speaking of everything every single
thing becoming super duper gay
we have got a a trailer for this movie
that my producers insist that I watch
it's called Bros
it's a movie it didn't do very well
apparently at the box office on opening
weekend it's apparently very very gay
they The Producers want to know if I
should review this movie give an actual
proper review we'll take a look at the
trailer together you tell me if we
should review the movie the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign